venez c'est grand jour
[Musique]
on va être en Staro note royale allons
vite nous marier quoi non je veux dire
allons vite voir Brigitte et graillon se
marier
j'avoue ça serait bizarre c'est nous on
se marie
trop bizarre
ment
dans la tête qui tourne
et diamants tu es le plus chaud de tous
les garçons de 9h papa arrête je suis le
plus chaud de tous les hommes d'honneur
mes chers amis Nous voici réunions
aujourd'hui pour arrêter ce mariage
je suis John et ça fait trop longtemps
que j'ai perdu de vue mon frère branche
tu es un des chanteurs de Brothers ou
bien juste de les écouter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était mon frère mes frères m'ont
abandonné et ils ne sont jamais revenus
proche on est plus un gros on est devenu
des hommes alors maintenant c'est plus
la même chose on va faire boys band à
part proche le moment est venu de
retrouver nos frères et reformer le
groupe
ça va être le meilleur
Frozone 2 3 0 les brodoudrini Rosa
petit diamant
dans une nouvelle aventure musicale et
dis donc le bouton qui est juste là tu
l'as vu tu veux parler du bouton sur
lequel j'essaie de toutes mes forces de
pas appuyer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]